[Music]
Toastmasters and guests, it is my
pleasure to welcome International President-Elect
Distinguished Toastmaster Margaret Page.
-Welcome to the 2021 World Championship of Public
Speaking Showcase. My name is Margaret Page,
and I am Toastmasters International
President-Elect and will be your emcee for this
showcase. Congratulations to all three contestants
who share this global virtual stage of the World
Championship of Public Speaking. Members and
guests, meet the 2021 World Championship winners:
World Champion Verity Price, second place winner
Nitay-Yair Levi, and our third-place winner
Roger Caesar. During today's showcase we are
going to speak with each winner for a few minutes.
But first I invite our new World Champion Verity
to enjoy two minutes to share acknowledgements
with our audience. Over to you, Verity.
-Thank you so much, Margaret. I-I must
say two minutes to say what I have to say would
take a lifetime, but I have 120 seconds so I will
start with the two most important words which are
thank you. I’m so humbled and happy and grateful
to have received this title today, I’m going
to be pinching myself for weeks to come.
Thank you to my club Toasted Toastmasters,
to my incredible District 74 Southern Africa,
who have supported me and sent me messages saying
it's time for Africa—and today we discovered that
it was. I am blown away to be the first winner
of this title in Africa, I hope that I have
broken the proverbial four-minute mile for
all speakers on this incredible continent,
because I really believe that this title can
come back to Africa many, many times. Thank
you to my husband who has looked after our
little boy so I could stay in the bedroom and
deliver speeches at all the incredible clubs that
have opened their doors to me across the world;
it's been the most extraordinary journey. I want
to also give a big shout out to Pres Vasilev for
his amazing compelling storytelling course that
I bought at the start of my journey and used
to help me craft my final speech. And then my
really big shout out to my coach, Lance Miller.
My favorite World Champ of all time, and to have
had the privilege of have you coach me, Lance,
and bring me to this point, I’m absolutely blown
away. It's been extraordinary. But mostly to you,
to Toastmasters International, to the audiences
that have made this possible for all of us, and
to my fellow contestants to share this stage with
you, I know only three of us could be at the top,
but all eight speeches today blew me away. To my
semi-finalists, to all the dreams that were born
in this contest and they're gonna come back to the
stage next year, I can't wait to-to see what you
bring. But if I can leave you with nothing else,
it's that right now I’m sitting in a room similar
to one that for many years felt like a prison.
And today it's shown me that a prison can turn
into a platform. And coming from South Africa
where our biggest inspiration, Nelson Mandela,
took imprisonment and turned it into a platform
for change, I believe that as speakers and as
leaders we can all do that. So, thank you from
the bottom of my heart, I am so grateful to
be your world champion and I’m going to be
punching myself for days to come. Thank you.
-Thank you, Verity, for your gracious
and inspiring words. You have thanked a
lot of people along your personal journey who
have influenced your success up to this very
moment. These acknowledgments are indicators of
a true Toastmaster leader, congratulations again.
Later in the showcase we will ask the winners
questions submitted by those of you watching us
live today. If you would like to submit a
question, please use the Q&A feature on the
platform, type in your question and hit send.
We will do our very best to get to as many
questions as possible. But please be aware, we
may not have time to get to all your questions.
So first, I have a few questions for our winners.
I’d like to go back to Verity again and ask,
what does it feel like to
be the 2021 World Champion
of Public Speaking? Take us through the
range of emotions you have experienced in
the last few hours since you were declared
the World Champion of Public Speaking.
-Margaret, I think I will feel what it feels
like—tomorrow when I wake up—at the moment,
I honestly can say I feel like I’m in a bubble,
but I was so privileged I got to watch with a
whole lot of family and friends the first time in
a long time that I had quite a few people with me.
And when it was announced the joy around me
of the people that believe in me and support
me…I just felt like it flooded through my whole
body, and we danced, and we sang, and we just
celebrated. We felt like we'd won a world cup.
And I just feel so grateful, and I think-I think
for me right now what's-what's settling in is that
the last six months and everything I’ve learned,
now it's time for me to figure out how
I share that and how I give that back,
especially into my District and into my fellow
members. Because I’ve got lots that I can share
now to make this journey easier for the ones
who come behind me. But I’m just over the moon.
-And we can see that and feel that for
you. But many people would like to be in
your shoes right now and share what that
immediate onrush of attention feels like.
-Also overwhelming, I haven't had a chance to get
to all the messages. And they've been flooding in
throughout this journey from—and I’m sure all my
fellow contestants have had this since winning
Districts. You just have people that believe in
you, that reach out that take the time to send
messages on social media platforms or WhatsApp,
and I have felt so connected and I think the big
thing for me that's come through this journey
is, alone I can't, together we can. And I’m sure
all my contestants will agree, none of us have
given a speech that we wrote by ourselves.
It's from the feedback that we've received, that
we've implemented, we've changed, we've grown, so
I can't wait to get to all the messages and
reply to everyone, but wow. Thank you. Thank
you for everything that's flooding in.
-Indeed. Together we can, right? Yeah.
So, Nitay-Yair, I’d like to go to you. How does
it feel to be the second-place winner of the ‘21
World Championship of Public Speaking? Um, take
us through the range of emotions you have felt.
-I-I don't-I don't still-I don't think I even
realized that here, you know, the-the magnitude
of that achievement. Uh, as Verity said, there's
a lot of work that goes straight, there's a lot
of people that help you, and-and just a moment in
time of something that had been happening for a
very long time and there's a lot of people
I need to thank, uh, for that moment. So,
I’ll echo Verity: I think only
tomorrow that will settle in
and only tomorrow I’ll realize what has been
achieved, and time to get ready for next year.
-Thank you, yes, indeed, tomorrow. Nitay-Yair,
what lasting impression do you hope your speech
made on the audience? If members
are talking about your speech
one year from now, what one thing
would you like them to be saying?
-In terms of the final speech is my message,
which perhaps sounds simple, but very hard to
do is to show love to those who are important to
you. Because they're there the whole time and you
take them sometime for granted. I have throughout
my past, especially with my mother which I love
very much. And it's very easy to-to take people
for granted. But they really shouldn't be,
because they love to use what propels you forward.
So, always show your love. Simple as that.
And as hard as it says-as it may not be to do.
-Thank you for those beautiful words.
Roger, how does it feel to be there on this big
virtual platform as the third-place winner of
the ‘21 World Championship of Public Speaking?
-It feels amazing. Absolutely amazing. It's
surreal, and I-I echo what
my fellow contestants said.
You-you go through all this process, the amount of
work, the-the coaching, the feedback that you get,
the support from all those around you, I
mean…you go through the entire process and
all you hope for is a chance. And that's what
it comes down to—a chance to get here so that
you could spread your message and be able to
inspire others. I mean for me in my message was
that—to inspire others to find their greatness
and I think by looking at all of these people,
Verity and Nitay-Yair and the other competitors
today…that's what they were doing: trying to
inspire our audience in our own way through our
stories, and make sure that they also can find
their greatness in some way, shape or form. So, I
am I’m thrilled, absolutely thrilled to be here.
-Well, we-we certainly found your
greatness. Roger, what inspired you
to write and speak about what has now become
your winning speech, entitled, “Is it in you?”
-Well, I’ll take you back to the speech that I
did in the semi-finals and…my father and I have
had this relationship where there are moments when
I was just cringing about him, and then there are
moments when I realized, “Wow he's such a great
man.” And my mom has always been that verbal
influence in my life, and I felt
that it was important that I
bring the two together and show how
much they have meant to me. My parents
mean the world to me. My sister, yeah, she
means something to me too…she will not be
singing anywhere, and that is okay with me,
but she means a lot to me. But my parents,
they have done so much hard work throughout the
years and the lessons that I have learned along
the way have been so instrumental in who I am
today and I’m proud. And that's why I wanted
people to understand that sometimes we don't see
those who are inspiring us, and they're right in
front of us. They're right there. Uh, Verity had
her dad, you know, uh, Nitay-Yair had his mom.
These are people that we don't see what they're
actually doing for us, and then all of a sudden
it [Snaps] clicks. That they're important to us.
So, this is what I wanted people to understand,
how valuable those people are around us. And-and
I have so many people to thank along the way.
-Indeed, those families mean so much to us and
teach us so much about life. Here's a question
that I’d love for all three of you to answer. How
did you modify your speech for a: your virtual
audience, and b: for your international
audience? And we'll go to Verity first.
-Thank you, thank you, Margaret. A lot of my
modifications happened from practicing with
clubs around the world and it was so helpful
for me because there was things in my speech,
like we lived in what we call a caravan, but when
I practiced in the United States they were like,
“We would call it a campervan,” and then I could
just tweak and change words slightly which was
so helpful. And in terms of the virtual
space, I think where we're lucky is we've
had a year-and-a-half of getting used to doing
this virtually. I was so inspired watching last
year's contest and particularly Mike Carr's
winning speech and how he used the screen. So,
you know, he and his fellow contestants paved the
way for me to play in this format. So, that for me
wasn't the difficult part. What was-was exciting
for me was getting the feedback from audiences
in Bangladesh, in India, Australia, UK, America,
and just finding language and imagery that had
as broad a universal connection. Otherwise,
if I’m only getting feedback in South Africa,
we often don't realize that we're just coming from
one point of view. Without this virtual world I
don't know if I would have been able to make it
as accessible as I feel like I did in the end.
-It was a real advantage this year wasn't it? And
yes, you are truly all pioneers here. Nitay-Yair,
how did you modify your speech for a: your virtual
audience and b: your international audience?
-This is a very, very interesting question,
Margaret, and I’ll answer it in two levels:
I think…for me this is about creating art. It's
called the art of public speaking, not public
speaking. And when you look at it as art you
need to go outside of the box and-and-and go as
crazy as you can, and then turn it down based on
feedback. And I had great, uh, coaches this year,
Pres Vasilev coached me this year and I thank you
very much. And Lou Beaton, who's listening I hope,
thank you as well. And the reason I
mentioned that is because you take these
crazy ideas and then they help you tone it
down to what's maybe palatable to the audience,
as opposed to scare the audience. Some of the
stuff I wanted to do perhaps were too extreme
for the virtual, uh, sense, but the feedback that
you get is great. So, that's number one you need,
that circle of confidence, uh, and obviously
Bill and-and Sherry helped on that too. The
other thing is the clubs visits and-and the
greatest advantage—I’m a fairly new toastmaster,
I’m only two years and a big toastmaster and this
year people like Keith Hardy and Janet open and
Alicia as well open the door for me, because I
don't know how many clubs, to visit over I don't
know 70 clubs around the world. And when you test
the messages, especially in my semi-final speech,
in-in Africa, or in Vietnam, or in Singapore,
or in the United States and I think Verity
touched on a very important point: your message
needs to be global. It needs to be simple and
global. You can't use terms that people won't
understand in different countries, and I have
originally at the beginning, so the feedback is
extremely important. A simple message, but the
key to me is to focus on your message and deliver
it in an artful way. If I can summarize it I just
focus on the art. But support your message, yeah.
-I love-I love that phrasing that public speaking
is an art, and that is truly, absolutely
correct. Roger, it's your turn now.
How did you modify your speech for your virtual
audience and for your international audience?
-Well for my final speech I had
created that speech a few years ago
and when I was, again as many of you have said
already, I worked with Pres Vasilev as well
in the first part of it in trying to create it
and-and have it for the in-person audience. And
I remember once we realized of course now that
we were going to be doing it online, there's a
lot of things that you have to change. I mean some
of the things that you would have in your speech,
and I’m sure that, uh, many of my other fellow
contestants can say the same thing, is that you
may have a moment where you're connecting with an
audience and you're looking one-on-one with them,
well now you're only looking at this little screen
right here, and you're trying so hard to make sure
that you can still bring your message through, and
they would feel it on the other side of that lens.
And that was what we had-I had to change when
I came to-when it came to the speech. So,
I worked with Craig Valentine this year and
he was instrumental in helping me to develop
the funny parts, the emotional parts, how to bring
it so that it can connect. But most importantly,
two people that I must-must thank and that
is Catherine McKenzie, who is the greatest
coach ever, and also Neil Dunsmore, who is a
great friend of mine, and we worked tirelessly
to make sure that we were able to work through
this little screen here and make it work. And
with regards to the global side of it, I will
say this: our stories are a gateway to our souls,
and it's the pathway to the audience's heart.
And what we try to do is make sure that when,
at least for myself, whatever message that I’m
sending out there, it is going to be universal.
You know, our stories are personal, but our
message has to be universal. And that was the
key to do something that, yes, could be personal
in my story, but the message itself everybody can
take away from, and that was important to me.
-We did definitely feel all your-all eight
speeches, they were just so remarkable.
And definitely, you countered our souls
with that-that, uh, entry point there. So, I
have another question for all three of you.
How has Toastmasters helped you personally and
professionally? But this time we will start with
Nitay-Yair. Would you like to
answer the first time-for the first-
-Oh, God. This is-I’m going to embarrass
myself now, but heck with it, let's do it. So,
when I got married to my wife, Simone, who I my-my
nickname for her is “Bundle of love with big brown
eyes,” that's what the name big brown eyes come
from, that's my nickname for her, and that's why I
named all the other characters based on the eyes.
And we got married and she's not a toastmaster,
I wasn't a toastmaster at the time, and she did
this speech in our wedding, and she killed it.
She would have beat everyone today on the
speech. I’m biased by the way, sorry, Verity.
So, the-the-the-and then I did my speech, and
it was a disaster. It was an absolutely bomb
in my own wedding and I thought, “Okay, that
needs to change. That is that is not good.”
Uh, and I was very—believed or not, very shy.
I’m still very shy, and-and I don't necessarily
feel comfortable speaking in front of a large
audience, so the Toastmaster-Toastmasters journey,
I joined this club in the City Tattersalls
club—which I represent today—and it took me
six months to do my icebreaker. I was that afraid.
Six months to do my icebreaker. But once I did my
icebreaker, uh, my mentor Mike Keanu MacCallum and
Peter Anderson as well immediately came and said,
uh, “You need to do the International Speech
Contest.” …on the same year! And-and what it did,
it-it-what Toastmaster's environment or the
mentors that I have in Toastmasters did, they gave
me confidence. And the thing is you have a skill
set but until you have the confidence to use the
skill set, it's just a skill set that is buried
somewhere underneath the ground. So, what it did,
it elevated the confidence. But beyond that, it
created a network of supporters and people who
help you push toward your dream going forward.
And that is something that you-just doesn't exist
anywhere else. People you don't even-there's
some people who help me who I haven't even met
physically. Who I haven't even met, and
they live in the US, I live in Australia,
and-and I just-it's incredible. So, how did it
help me? Confidence. Absolutely confidence. You
know, we all have something burning inside,
the question is how do you bring it out?
For me that was Toastmasters.
-That was a beautiful story beautiful,
beautiful story and I hope we will hear the
speech about you and your wife, uh, a full
five-to-seven minutes and not-on another time but
thank you for that. And the Toastmaster family
is definitely remarkable we'll-we are a unique
organization; only things like that happen here.
Roger, your turn. How has Toastmasters
helped you personally and professionally?
-Well, I’ll share my story. When I took over the
family business I used to walk into a lot of the
companies that we work with and they knew me while
my dad was around as just ‘hey it's Roger, how you
doing, Roger? What's going on?’ And when I took
over the business, you saw the change in how they
reacted to me and it was more like, ‘oh, here's
the owner so let's, uh, let's see what he's
about.’ And I remember sitting in an executive
office one day and he had just become the new
supervisor of the company that we work with,
and it was the first time ever I encountered
trying to speak to an introvert, and I had
no idea how to have a conversation with him,
and I remember leaving his office and coming
back to mind and saying some words that I
can't say because we're Toastmasters. I
couldn't say it and of course I looked up
how to improve my speaking abilities,
and that's how I got into Toastmasters.
And I’ll never forget my first speech that I did
when I did my icebreaker. There was a gentleman
there named Sanjay Sharma and once I finished
he came over he tapped my shoulders, and I think
everybody has one of these stories…I’m hoping.
But he tapped my shoulder after, and he goes,
“You're gonna be a champion one day, I can
feel it. I know it, I know it in my soul,”
and I laughed at him. Well, I’m not laughing
anymore, thank you, Sanjay, for that. So, that's
where it is for me. Personally and professionally,
Toastmasters has helped me build my confidence and
be able to feel comfortable speaking, whether
in person or right now on the virtual stage.
-Thank you for sharing that story too, very
special and precious—I guarantee no one said
that to me, “you will be champion,” so, they only
say it to those that are-have it within them. Well
done, Roger. Verity, how has Toastmasters
helped you personally and professionally?
-I joined Toastmasters for fun 10 years ago.
My sister had joined it to overcome her fear
of public speaking and I used to go to meetings
just to support at Two Oceans Toastmasters and I
loved it. I would do table topics and I thought it
was great. I was a professional singer and already
speaking at the time, so it was really like
this is something interesting for me to do once
a month. But I was also moments away from living
in the spare room and suffering from quite severe
depression and anxiety. And so, how Toastmasters
helped me was personally, it put me into an
organization where suddenly I had a purpose bigger
than myself. I was invited to join the committee
and I joined as a treasurer and someone who did
very bad at maths, I couldn't believe they were
trusting me with the books. But suddenly I was
part of a team, and I actually joined a second
club so that I would have a reason to get up on
a Wednesday morning and go to a meeting. I was
really suffering from bad depression at the time.
And it was a conscious choice, this organization
is going to help me. There's people here, there's
community, there's a sense of camaraderie. And so,
I kept showing up…and I had to overcome my
arrogance that I was already sorted as a speaker,
because my sister, Kay, in the club contest in
2012 beat me and I was very unimpressed because
she'd only done a cc6 and she went on to come
second to Ryan Avery in the semi-finals that year.
And I suddenly learned that you need to read
the manual and there is always something you
could learn, and you have to be mentored, and
you can't think you know everything. And so,
I’m only here today because I’ve spent nine years
listening in this organization, taking feedback
and leaning into the leadership opportunities it's
given me, because that's where it's really changed
me. It's changed the way I run my business, after
being treasurer, I’ve never struggled to get money
out of a client again. It's been amazing, so it's
been life-changing and I might gloss over the fact
that I was in a spare room eating ice cream and
Netflix, but it was a very dark time in my life,
and this organization gave me purpose
through that. So, I will be forever grateful
and forever looking for ways to
give back to this organization.
-We're so thankful that you got over the ice
cream and the, uh, Netflix binging for sure.
And thank you for that about reading the manual,
now the project, right? You-you have to read-yes,
do the work. Do the work together. Thank you
all for those answers, they were beautiful.
But right now, we want to hear from Verity on how
many times have you presented that speech you gave
during the World Championship of Public Speaking,
and what did your coaches or mentors say or do
that made the difference in your decision
to pursue this World Champion title?
-So, the speech I gave today I wrote exactly 100
days ago. And the reason I know that is it came to
me at two in the morning and the original version,
although very similar to the story I told today,
was also sharing that I had done one of the things
I did based on my father's advice was a 100 happy
days challenge—to just take pictures of things
that made me happy. And so, when I wrote the
speech I thought, “you know what?” And I looked
at the date, and I was like, “Gosh, it's exactly a
hundred days till the world finals and if this was
the speech I would give, I’m gonna do my hundred
happy days while I give the speech.” And really,
today has been the happiest day of my life.
But I’ve given the speech hundreds of times.
It's changed its message multiple times
and through working with Lawrence Miller as my-my
coach and he just gently pushed me and guided me,
he didn't ever kind of push me into directions I
didn't want to go in, but he held the space for me
to question decisions I was making, try different
things. And through the feedback I had, we only
ended up—I’d write a different story two weeks ago
and I actually would like to—so, the same the same
speech, just the thread came through and that was
feedback, uh, from a toastmaster in South Africa,
and he just he made one comment in his evaluation
to me, and it made me re-look at the whole speech.
And suddenly it just came together. So, I will be
forever grateful. And that is why I say to anyone
if you choose to go on this journey, deliver your
speech to as many people as you can. Suck it up,
take the feedback, it's not always easy; my ego
has been bruised and some of it's been brutal, but
I’ve had to listen. And go, “Is there something,
and if three people have said the same thing,
am I open to change?” So, I have been giving
this speech for 100 days, it has changed me,
it has shaped me, it has challenged me. But I
would never -would never do it any other way
other than rewriting and rewriting and
redelivering and tweaking and changing,
up until the day of the finals there was little
moments that were still coming to me. So,
I’m sure there's 10 other versions I could give
but I’m very grateful that I’ve now done it.
-Well, that was outstanding to hear how many
times it takes, and really, how long you have
to work at something till that ultimate idea,
that concept, that really getting it within you,
how long that can sometimes take. So, for all of
us, we need to keep working, keep working. We have
so many questions from the audience. We're going
to go to audience questions now. So, the first one
is, “There is a thin line between being
vulnerable and over sharing. How do each of you
navigate this fine line?” So, let's
go to Roger first and then Nitay-Yair.
-That is an absolutely great question. The reality
is-is as speakers the way you connect with your
audience is being vulnerable. Is allowing them
to see that inner human side of you. I think it's
very important to share that. Now the thin line,
yes, you don't want to share too much sometimes
because you don't want to expose yourself, but I
kind of look at it from a different perspective.
And that is that there is somebody in that
audience whether we are in person or virtually,
there's somebody there that is waiting to hear
a particular message. And sometimes when we as
speakers go out there and we speak, it could take
just you opening up yourself and talking about
something that has happened to you that will help
that one person in the audience. And I’ll give you
a quick example. I went and I spoke once at
an open house and I talked about, you know,
fear in an event that had happened to me before
and this gentleman came up to me after the event
and he said, “You know what, it's funny you
did that. I wasn't going to come here today,
but somebody said, ‘you know, come and see
this guy.’” And when I finished, he said,
“I was going to go to my lawyers at-after work
at about four o'clock today and sign papers
to divorce my wife because I thought she was
the one that was at fault for everything that
happened in our relationship.” He said, “After
I heard your speech, I realized it was me that
needed to change the things that were going on
with me. And now we're trying to reconcile that
we're going to go and reconcile things.” These are
those moments that you as a speaker just go, “Oh,
I didn't know I could do that,” but that's
why being vulnerable and allowing yourself
to share your stories—It can help someone else
to cure their own problems that they're having.
-Absolutely. What a gift this tool is, right, to
be able to share with others and have impact on
their life and influence them in a positive way.
Thank you for doing that. So, Nitay-Yair, over to
you. I’ll read the question again to you from the
audience. “There's a thin line between building
vulnerable-” sorry, “-to being vulnerable and over
sharing. How did you navigate this fine line?”
-The truth is I’m not sure I’m able to navigate
that fine line and that's-that's the absolute
truth. Um, my personal view is this: if there's
something, a message that is burning in you, you
need to get it out. And you need to-to put all the
shields and all the walls that you put around you
and just share it. And it makes me emotional
now because that's just the truth. And if you
share your message raw, people will
connect. But you need to be careful;
you need to lift them up at the end
of it. You need to open your heart,
say, “This is who I am. You may not like it,
but this is who I am,” and then close it and
take them back up because you-you don't want them
more depressed than-than when they come and saw
your speech. But unless-unless you go in and show
them the real you, um, I don't-I don't believe
that there will be any connection. That's my
personal view. I’m not probably the best person
to answer that question because I-I don't know
how to separate it too, I really don't. Yeah.
-Thank you, yeah, thank you for that share,
you—and all of you really did lift us up,
you were marvelous at that. All right,
Verity, I’ll-I’ll read it again. “There's
a thin line between being vulnerable and over
sharing; how did you navigate this fine line?”
-Well similar to Nitay-Yair, I’m-I am a very
honest person; my name means truth, so I tend
to speak about what I’ve dealt with. But I think
the-the line for me is and-and I can't remember
where I heard this, but they say you should never
speak about something until you can laugh about
it. So, even if it was a heartbreaking,
you know, shameful, difficult situation,
don't speak about it until you've dealt with it.
So, I tend to talk about quite difficult things
that I’ve gone through, and I-I can laugh at
myself and I’m not afraid to share my flaws. I’m
less than perfect and-and I talk about
that often, but I’m not using my talk as
personal therapy. And maybe that is
where we see something as over sharing,
is we're using the talk to maybe try
and process it in front of an audience,
whereas the audience as Nitay-Yair said wants
to be lifted up. So, be honest. Be vulnerable.
Open up your arms, you know, own your shame.
People grow and-and Roger said this as well,
we don't know how we might shape someone by
being honest about what we've struggled with.
But I think for me, I share it once I’ve worked
through it. I couldn't have given this speech
six years ago. I wasn't ready. I can now laugh
at myself in the spare room and there's times I
still will eat ice cream and eat-watch Netflix and
that's okay. It's part of my process, but I don't
need the audience to heal me, I’m healing myself.
-Thank you for that distinction and that share.
So, this message came from the audience, they
wanted to congratulate all three winners and they
would like to know if this is your first attempt
at the World Championship of Public Speaking.
And we'll let Roger answer that first. Roger?
-Great, great. This is my fourth time. This is
the fourth time I have been here. I-I must admit
I wasn't planning on competing this year and,
again, my good friend Neil Dunsmore and
I had a conversation and we said, “Look,
let's just go out there and have a
good time and see where it takes us.”
And so, we both decided to compete and
eventually both made it to the District.
I was able to come out on top and he
got second and ever since that point,
he has been right beside me, so…it was a-it
was a-an opportunity again to try something new
which was this virtual platform. But yes, three
times before and this-this I guess is the charm.
-And every time you get better and better, right?
-Feels very good, honestly.
Very, very good, thank you.
-All right, thanks. Verity, how
about you? Shall I read the—
-First time, yeah? It's all good. First time was
2012 and I didn't prepare, and my sister beat me
at club, and that was when I discovered there
was the World Championship of Public Speaking,
and it opened my eyes to it. Second time was
2015 and I got as far as Division and came third.
And I-and the only reason I’m here today is
because of lockdown and because of COVID. I
became a mother, I had left Toastmasters and if
we hadn't gone virtual and my club Toasted hadn't
needed some help with getting the club getting
going again 18 months ago, I probably wouldn't
have rejoined as a member yet. I was right in
the middle of motherhood, but suddenly we were
virtual, and I could do it because I could close
the door and I could practice around the world,
and I’m just absolutely blown
away that I’ve ended up here
today and I’m so grateful. So, so grateful.
-Sounds like you're-was your destiny. Nitay-Yair,
how about you? Was this your first attempt
at the World Championship of Public Speaking?
-So, I in my first year at Toastmasters I
competed in the International Speech contest,
and I’ve done a speech and one of my
mentors, Mike Keanu McCallum, said-I
mentioned that before, he said, “You need to
do the International Speech-” this is after my
icebreaker, “-you need to do the International
Speech Contest,” and I said, “Of course I do!”
And then I went to the person next to me, I
said, “What's the International Speech Contest?”
I had no idea what it meant. So, I did I-did go
in that year, and with the help of Louise Beaton,
I—who was a contestant in-she was competing
against me in a club, and she beat me,
because I competed in two clubs—and she-she was
helping me and I was very lucky in my first year,
extremely lucky and fortunate to win the District
and progress to the Quarterfinals. I did not
progress beyond the Quarterfinals. And I think
the first time I did it, it was-I-I still don't
know anything, I’m still learning, I always learn.
And-and I was still discovering the tools in the
thing that is called the art of public speaking.
So, I was patching myself as I was competing,
and-and I presume that's the
reason why I didn't progress beyond
the regionals. This year is my second year,
and-and I think the-the advantage as you do
it over and over again, and I can't wait to
do it next year, is you-you don't learn...you
now know the tools and you now can experiment
with the tools, and you can become a true artist
in in what you do. I’m not there, that-the-the
road is still long, but this is my second year
and-and my second time I’m doing this, and-and
I just can't wait for next year. I really can't.
-Thank you. You-you seem like you're so full of
energy and-and ready to get started already on-on
the next speech for sure. Here's the next
question from our audience, and I’ll go to you
again first, Nitay-Yair, “What motivated
you to keep going after your first
embarrassing moment during
your Toastmasters journey?”
-Sorry, I’m not sure I-I understand the-the
question. So, what made me go forward after
the embarrassing moment, my first embarrassing
moment at Toastmasters, is that right?
-I-I believe the person—I don't want to
put words in their mouth, but they may be
making the assumption that each of us have had an
embarrassing moment and we've pushed beyond that.
-I see. And they're not wrong, they're not wrong.
And I think especially when-when-especially
when you experiment, and-and all of us visited
clubs obviously too, I didn't realize that the
concept of visiting clubs existed last year. It
was just me and some-and Louise, essentially.
And-and this year when I visited clubs and I
tried, you know, the time travel and, oh, I
bombed so many times! It was horrible. Oh, and you
just fail and fail and fail. But-but if you are
in the mindset of ‘I have a message to deliver,
I’m experimenting,’ this is an experiment ground
to try different tools, to push that message
forward. And some of them may not work and that's
okay, but you're experimenting. And then you
choose the right tools at competition, um, that's
what drives you forward. Because you understand
that the feedback you get is not to destroy you,
but actually to build you. And that's the
greatest thing about Toastmasters—the feedback.
-Thank you for that. Verity, what about
you? After your first embarrassing moment
during your Toastmaster journey,
what helped you push through?
-I would have to agree with Nitay-Yair, it's very
much in this contest journey, uh, before this,
speeches were just part of the program, and I was
having fun at my club. But putting myself in the
spotlight as a contestant and receiving a lot of
feedback and sometimes having things go wrong,
I’ve had some-some low moments over the last few
months and “why am I doing this” and “is it any
good” and then you come back to the message. And I
go, “I’m here because I have something to say. I’m
here because I believe in it and the feedback
I’m getting is going to help it get better.
So, I need to get over myself, I need to go back
to the drawing board, do some tweaks and then go
practice at a club and be okay with things not
being okay.” And so, for me it really is can I
be okay with things not being okay? And if
I need a bit of time to-to lick my wounds
after a particular fall, that's all right. But
it's do I get back up and-and what makes me get
back up is the message if-each and every time.
-Oh, thank you for that beautiful share.
Roger, you look really serious there for a
moment, so I think you've got something you
went to a moment in time, but what motivated you
to keep going after your first embarrassing
moment during your Toastmasters journey?
-Well, mine would be again in a comp-in
competitive fashion. It was in 2015 and I shared
this earlier at the other showcase. My grandmother
had passed away two days before I was heading to
Las Vegas for the World Championships, and I was
doing a speech about her. And while I was there
for the first two days I was going through
an array of emotions, I was doubting myself
constantly, wondering why I was coming here to do
this speech when I was feeling the way I was about
her passing away. And then five minutes before
going on stage I went right into a convenience
store and bought myself a mirror as a prop. Now
everybody knows you don't practice a prop on the
greatest moment right there, that you should be
practicing this well before. And I chose to do it
then and I went on stage, and I got to that part
where I pulled the mirror out of my pocket and
said my line, and then I went to put the mirror
back and it would not go back into the pocket.
And I was sitting on stage trying to play
it off so much times and then it fell onto
the ground. Um, I believe it was my grandmother
saying from the heavens above, “Why would you
do that when you knew the speech well?” And I
remember I was so embarrassed from that moment,
but it was great people when I got back to my
District that constantly was picking me up and
realizing how painful that moment was for me.
And even, again a good friend of mine, Neil,
he would make jokes about it but I’m gonna go with
what Verity said. You have to be able to laugh
about it afterwards and that's what I was able
to do. It took about a year and a half before
I was able to just go, “Oh well, I dropped the
mirror,” and then I pushed forward and then I did
a speech about it—about dropping the mirror.
So, that was the easiest way to get over it
and that has-is what has propelled me to continue
forward and just deliver speeches and know
how those vulnerable moments can actually
help not only the audience but yourself.
-Thank you for that share, particularly
about that we as Toastmasters, we may
not be wanting to compete ourselves but
what an influence that we have and what an
impact that we can have on those in our club
to keep going and to keep motivating. So,
keep on sharing those positive messages.
This next question is just directed to
Nitay-Yair, and this is, “Where did you get
the idea of the black screen flashback?”
-Okay, so the approach I took this year is to
focus on the art of public speaking and not on
public speaking, and I’m emphasizing
the art. And-and the way-the way-the
way I approached it is it-everything starts with a
message, so you have your well-crafted message and
now you're looking for tools to push it forward,
right? And I thought okay because we're talking
about art, let's look outside of public speaking.
And there's different elements that happens there
and-and to that particular thing, I took it from
three different art forms. One is beatboxing,
you know, because I was looking for sound for the
transfer. So, it's like-so that's a beatbox-sorry,
I-I’ve found a sound that they used in movies,
but I couldn't do it, so I looked at beatboxing,
how they-how they do the sound. That's how I
formulated the-the sound. The-the covering of the
screen and opening, I took from TikTok—I-I'm not
a TikTok user, but I see-I see my little sister
is. She's always on TikTok, she sends me these
videos and you know. But they edit the video,
they cover the-the screen and then when they open
it then on a beach. You know, they edit the video.
I said, oh, that's a cool transition. So, that's
from Y generation or Z generation, I’m not, I’m
generation X. So, that's another art form, right,
of movies editing movies? But the issue I had is,
okay, how do I go from very close to the screen
all the way to the back in a split second, yeah?
And that's from dance, so it's actually only two
steps. So, just this transition which looks very
simple has three different art forms in it. One is
from beatbox, how to do the sound. Two is from a
transition from TikTok or from media, which I’m
not an expert in that. And three is from dance,
how to do the two steps which appears very quickly
taking you to-to the other side of the screen. So,
that's how I did it. How did I come up with
it? Um, I think you just need to be creative
and think, “Okay, I don't want to just step
back, let's spice it up a little bit.” And
by the way that wasn't always the transition, I
had different transitions that I experiment with.
This was the one that best served the message
from the ones that I came up with. That's it.
-Fascinating to bring in concepts
from other art forms and to utilize it
in this environment. Our next question will go
to Roger first, “What was your main inspiration
for deciding to compete, and what were you
expecting to get from this whole journey?”
-That's a good question. The inspiration
to compete was, again, Sanjay Sharma.
I didn't come into Toastmasters to
compete, I just wanted to feel comfortable
speaking in front of small crowds, in executive
office, in-in front of those types of situations.
And it was him that kind of put that, you know,
that little fire. Set that fire off and that was
the inspiration that I needed, and then constantly
looking at so many members in my club at the time.
Those who were in-were competing that were
much better than me, I would study them,
look at them learn from them and then try to craft
my own style from that. And-what was your second
question? I’m sorry, the second part?
-It was, “What were you expecting
to get from the whole journey?”
-Just to learn more about myself, to look at other
established and well-seasoned speakers. And
look, we have here individuals who are very
new to Toastmasters and still made it here, and
they have so much to offer, even for me who's
been in Toastmasters for 10 years. I’m looking
at this and I am going to say it right now,
Nitay-Yair, I am jealous because when
you did that move, I was saying, “Whoa,
I wish I could have done learned something
to do in my speech when I was saying,
you know, when you were-if you've been
blind by those who inspire you,” I was
trying to figure out something else like,
“My hand doesn't look good there like that.”
That was so cool, so I want to tell you
that right now publicly, so. But, you know,
when I see that that's for me what it all comes
down to—developing my skills, learning how to
become better and watching the very best and we
can learn from them, so that's what it is for me.
-Beautiful. And I love that you shared that's
the accolades for each of-you know, you're all
in this together and you're just so supportive of
one another that-I’ve noticed that when we were
preparing for the World Championship how
supportive you all are of each other and enjoying
each other's placements. Well done. Verity, over
to you on that same question. What was your main
inspiration for deciding to compete? What were
you expecting to get from this whole journey?
-My inspiration came last year when I wrote-I
started the pathways journey, and I did my
icebreaker, and I shared the story of walking on
the beach with my parents and being embarrassed
by them. And something in me, like this little
voice said, “This could be a contest speech.” And
probably two years earlier, I remember thinking
I’ve been lucky to win quite a few of the other
contests at District level and I thought, “You
know what? The one thing I’m never going to win
is the International Speech Contest. I just don't
have a speech that works.” And suddenly this voice
said, “I think the speech could go there,” and I
listened. I listened and it has changed so much,
my semi-final speech from what I delivered
at club level and all the way through,
and-and with it came this dream of like
‘but-but what if I could go all the way?’
And it's been this incredible tug-of-war inside
of me and I try to explain it to someone, I said,
“This whole journey has felt like going on
your first date with someone and thinking
this is the person I’m going to marry and
having clarity that this is your future,
you know, partner. And then you've still
got to date them, and you've still got to
see if it's going to work out.” So, I’ve had
this tug-of-war, like maybe this could take
me all the way, but oh, I’m not sure, I’m
not sure. So, for me the journey was…I’ve
never really pushed myself where I’ve had to give
it everything. I’ve always done enough to do well
in life, and this was deeply uncomfortable.
This was “sit down, write, rewrite, feedback,
try again,” and-and I put myself in it
for that and I put my-my name in the hat,
and I owned that I wanted to go as far as I could.
And it was so scary to even say that out loud.
And I’m so grateful I did, because it has,
it's-well, it's changed my life and I know
it is going to continue to change my life. But
what I can say to people is when you have that
little voice that says, ‘maybe this could go
somewhere,’ listen and see where it takes you.
-That is-that's a good voice, isn't it? To hear
that we have that-those two sides that's saying,
‘You can do it,’ and that's saying, ‘Yeah, I
don't think so.’ And, uh, to go in between those
voices. That's the key, and you did it and pushed
yourself beyond, so bravo and we are so thankful
that you did. Nitay-Yair, what about the
same thing? What was your main inspiration
for deciding to compete, and what were you
expecting to get from your whole journey?
-So, I have to be-I’ll answer that in
two parts—actually, three parts. Uh,
last year was my first year in Toastmasters, the
first year I’ve done the contest, I wanted to win.
And that was the wrong reason to go into this
competition, absolutely the wrong reason.
This year, I-I said, “Okay, obviously the semi's
final-the semi speech was the one that brought
me to the finals,” and that message was very raw
and very important to me, “The Scars of the Past.”
If you haven't watched it, the audience, please
do; it's a message that is very important to me.
And-and I decided to do against all the advice,
remove nearly all the humor in the compe-in
the speech, and that's the dedication that I
had to-to the message. I decided to focus on the
message and whatever that means contest-wise, so
be it. And I looked at the contest as a platform
to share that message with other people. And we
started in my club in my area, and then thankfully
people appreciated the message, so I focused
on the message. But there's another component
to it to-to-which is the semis. I won't go too
much into the details, but I nearly didn't-did
not compete in the semi-finals. I had some, uh,
issue and in 48 hours I was ready to pull out of
the contest. And then what inspired me to do that,
and I’m getting emotional just thinking about it,
is LaShunda Rundles. Um, yeah, LaShunda Rundles.
I’ve never met her, I-I’ve only seen her speeches.
And I thought if she could do it, if she could
deliver a speech—and I’m getting emotional
thinking about it—I have no reason why I can't do
it. There's no reason. So, if you believe in your
message you're just gonna do it. That's-that's
the inspiration that you need to have. And I’m
very thankful that she existed and-and gave me
that inspiration to do the semis, simple as that.
-Well thank you for mentioning her, she, was
a remarkable person. Absolutely, for sure. And
that wisdom about don't focus on the win, focus on
the message. Focus on the message. Thank you. So,
we have time for one more, and the question was
“How did you,” …oh, this one is the last question
and it's a good one: “What will you do next?” And
we'll go with Roger first and then Nitay and over
to Verity. So, Roger, what will you do next?
-I’m going to go to Disney World. [Laughter]
I really wanted to say that, but… you know
what? I’m going to take some time. I’m going
to take some time off; I’ve been competing for the
majority of my Toastmasters journey; I’m going to
take some time to myself and do what I do-what I
love doing the most and that is helping others to
finally achieve their goals and their dreams. I
know that there are so many people in District 86
and now in District 123 that I can help and
get them to see what they can possibly do,
what dreams they may have. So, I’m gonna focus
on that for now, take some time to just relax
and…who knows? You never know. Maybe I might
come back, maybe I won't. for me right now
it's about seeing the rest of my District
that have been so supportive of me,
that I try to help them and the great speakers
that we have in both those Districts now.
-Oh, thank you for that.
Nitay-Yair, what will you do next?
-In line for Toastmasters? That's-that's two
separate questions. Uh, I was very fortunate
in the last two days to spend time with the
family, and that's something that obviously
my incredible wife sacrificed in support, so I’m
very, very thankful for her support, otherwise
I wouldn't be-I wouldn't be here. In terms of the
Toastmasters journey, my heart is already hurting,
and my brain is already exploding because
there's so much-so many messages I want to-I
want to bring out. So, this morning I already
started writing the speech for-for next year.
And I’m actually not joking; I’m fully serious.
And the reason being this is the greatest thing
about Toastmasters, because I was very shy for
a long time, and-and you have a lot of desire
inside but when it's all locked and you're unable
to express it and then this comes, this amazing
platform and that teaches you all the tools and
craft how to express it…I mean God bless, this is
a blessing! How can you not want to do it? Yeah?
-Well thank you for that, we're so grateful that
“Brown Eyes” has allowed you to have some more
time with us and that she's letting you continue
to do what you've come to love, absolutely.
All right, Verity, what will you do next?
-Oh, other than spend some much-needed time
with my family who have been missing me,
I’ve got a lot of thank-you letters to
write to everyone who supported me. But
taking some time back and then in terms of my
work and what I’m passionate about, my final
speech has given me a whole new direction and I’m
very inspired to start working on a program that
whether I’m offering it into my clients
or I’m not sure yet it's-it's percolating,
but how to help people write a different story,
and what's really exciting is it actually brings
my music back to life. I walked away from my
professional music career 10-10-11 years ago,
and suddenly I’m seeing that my songs
and the speech, there's something there.
So, I’m just saying that out loud because that's
what's here right now. I feel like this is my next
bit of work. And, uh, in terms of Toastmasters…
[Clears throat] Excuse me, too much speaking.
In terms of Toastmasters, it's how do I bring back
what I’ve learned to my District, like Roger was
saying. And I’m just so excited to help the-the
other incredible speakers in Southern Africa get
the opportunity to hopefully get to where I’m
sitting today, so that's-that's my commitment.
-Outstanding. Thank you for sharing,
we look forward to seeing that, uh,
evolve and how you help others write a different
story, those that are in need. Thank you so much.
And thank you and congratulations again to each
of our 2021 World Championship Winners. You have
reached this goal after many months of hard work,
practice and refinement of your speaking skills,
or the speaking art. Enjoy this moment, because
you have definitely earned it. Members and guests,
thank you for attending this showcase, it's been
a pleasure to have each of you here with us today.
[Applause]